[Music]
I study acts and that's because I like
to think about how organizations work
and in particular how the simple parts
of organizations interact to create the
behavior of the whole organization so
ant colonies are a good example of an
organization like that and there are
many others the web is one there are
many biological systems like that brain
cells developing embryos there are about
10,000 species of ants they all live in
colonies consisting of one or a few
Queens and then all the ants you see
walking around are sterile female
workers and all ant colonies have in
common that there's no central control
nobody tells anybody what to do the
Queen just lays the eggs there's no
management no ant directs the behavior
of any other ant and I try to figure out
how that works and I've been working for
the past 20 years on a population of
seed-eating ants in southeastern Arizona
here's my study site this is really a
picture of ants in the rabbit just
happens to be there and these ants are
called harvester ants because they eat
seeds this is the nest of a mature
colony and there's the nest entrance and
they forage maybe for about 20 meters
away gather up the seeds and bring them
back to the nest and store them and
every year I go there and make a map of
my study site this is just a road and
it's not very big it's about 250 meters
on one side 400 on the other and every
colony has a name which is a number
which is painted on a rock and I go
there every year and look for all the
colonies that were alive the year before
and figure out which ones have died and
put all the new ones on the map and by
doing this I know how old they all are
and because of that I've been able to
study how their behavior changes as the
colony gets older and larger so I want
to tell you about the lifecycle of a
colony so ants never make more ants
colonies make more colonies and they do
that by each year sending out the
reproductives those are the
with wings on a mating flight so every
year on the same day and it's a mystery
exactly how that happens each colony
sends out its Virgin unmated Queens with
wings and the males and they all fly to
a common place and they make and this
shows recently Virgin Queen hears her
wings and she's in the process of mating
with this male and there's another male
on top waiting his turn often the
Queen's mate more than once and after
that the males all die that's it for
them and then the newly mated Queens fly
off somewhere drop their wings dig a
hole and go into that hole and start
laying eggs and they will live for 15 or
20 years continuing to lay eggs using
the sperm from that original mating so
the Queen goes down in there she lays
eggs she feeds the larvae so an ant
starts as an egg then it's a larvae she
feeds the larvae by regurgitating from
her fat reserves then as soon as the
ants the first group of ants emerge
their larvae then their pupae then they
come out as adult ants they go out they
get the food they dig the nest and the
Queen never comes out again so this is a
one-year-old colony this happens to be
5:36 there's the nest entrance there's a
pencil for scale so this is the colony
founded by a queen the previous summer
this is a three year old colony there's
the nest entrance there's a pencil for
scale they make a midden a pile of
refuse mostly the husks of the seeds
that they eat this is a five year old
colony this is the nest entrance here's
a pencil for scale this is about as big
as they get about a meter across and
then this is how colony size in numbers
of worker ants changes and so this is
about 10,000 worker ants changes as a
function of colony age in years so it
starts out with zero ants just the
founding Queen and it grows to a size of
about ten or twelve thousand ants when
the colony is five and it stays that
size until the Queen dies and there's
nobody to make more ants when she's
about
fifteen or twenty years old and it's
when they reach this stable size in
numbers of ants that they start to
reproduce that is to send more wing 'add
queens and males to that year's mating
flight and I know how colony size
changes as a function of colony age
because I've dug up colonies of known
age and counted all the ends so that's
not the most fun part of this research
although it's interesting so really the
question that I think about with these
ants is what I call task allocation
that's not just how is the colony
organized but how does it change what
it's doing how is it that the colony
manages to adjust the numbers of workers
performing each task as conditions
change so things happen to an ant colony
when it rains in the summer it floods in
the desert there's a lot of damage to
the nest and extra answer needed to
clean up that mess when extra food
becomes available and this is what
everybody knows about picnics then extra
ants are allocated to collect the food
so with nobody telling anybody what to
do how is it that the colony manages to
adjust the numbers of workers performing
each task and that's the process that I
call task allocation and in harvester
ants I divide the tasks of the ants I've
seen just outside the nest into these
four categories where an ant is foraging
when it's out along the foraging trail
searching for food or bringing food back
the patrollers that's supposed to be a
magnifying glass are an interesting
group that go out early in the morning
before the foragers are active they
somehow choose the direction that the
foragers will go and by coming back just
by making it back they tell the foragers
that it's safe to go out then the nest
maintenance workers work inside the nest
and I wanted to say that the nest look a
lot like bill Lishman house that is that
their chambers inside they lined the
walls of the Chamber's with moist soil
and it dries to a kind of Adobe like
surface in it it also looks very similar
to some of the cave dwellings of the
Hopi people that are in that area and
the nest maintenance workers do that
inside the nest and then the
come out of the nest carrying bits of
dry soil and their mandibles so you see
the nest maintenance workers come out
with a bit of sand put it down turn
around and go back in and finally the
midden workers put some kind of
territorial chemical in the garbage so
what you see the midden workers doing is
making a pile of refuse on one day and
all be here and then the next day
they'll move it over there and then
they'll move it back so that's what the
midden workers do and these four groups
are just the ants outside the nest so
that's only about 25% of the colony and
they are the oldest ants so an ounce
starts out somewhere near the Queen and
when we dig up nests we find they're
about as deep as the colony is wide so
about a metre deep for the big old nest
and then there's another long tunnel and
a chamber where we often find the Queen
after eight hours of hacking away at the
rock with pickaxes I don't think that
chamber has evolved because of me and my
backhoe and like who have students with
pickaxes but instead because when
there's flooding occasionally the colony
has to go down deep so there's this
whole network of chambers the Queen's in
there somewhere she just lays eggs
there's the larvae and they consume most
of the food and this is true of most
ants that the ants you see walking
around don't do much eating they bring
it back and feed it to the larvae when
the foragers come in with food they just
drop it into the upper chamber and other
ants come up from below get the food
bring it back husks the seeds and pile
them up their nest maintenance workers
working throughout the nest and
curiously and interestingly it looks as
though at any time about half the ants
in the colony are just doing nothing so
despite what it says in the Bible about
you know look to the ant thou sluggard
in fact you could think of those ances
reserves that is to say if something
happened and I've never seen anything
like this happen but I've only been
looking for 20 years if something
happened they might all come out if they
were needed but in fact mostly they're
just hanging around in there and I think
it's a very interesting question what is
there about the way the colony that is
organized that might give some function
to a reserve of ants who are doing
nothing and
sort of stand as a as a buffer in
between the ants working deep inside the
nest and the ants working outside and if
you mark ants that are working outside
and dig up a colony you never see them
deep down so what's happening is that
the ants work inside the nest when
they're younger they somehow get into
this reserve and then eventually they
get recruited to join this exterior work
force and once they belong to the ants
that work outside they never go back
down now that's most ants including
these don't see very well they have eyes
they can distinguish between light and
dark but they mostly work by smell so
just to reinforce that what you might
have thought about at Queen's isn't true
you know even if the Queen
did have the intelligence to send
chemical messages through this whole
network of chambers to tell the ants
outside what to do there is no way that
such messages could make it in time to
see the shifts in the allocation of
workers that we actually see outside the
nest so that's one way we know that the
queen isn't isn't directing the behavior
of the colony so when I first set out to
work on task allocation my first
question was what's the relationship
between the ants doing different tasks
does it matter to the foragers what the
nest maintenance workers are doing does
it matter to the midden workers what the
patrollers are doing and I was working
in the context of a view of ant colonies
in which each ant was somehow dedicated
to its task from birth and sort of
performed independently of the others
knowing its place on the assembly line
and instead I wanted to ask how are the
different task groups interdependent so
I did experiments where I changed one
thing so for example I created more work
for the nest maintenance workers by
putting out a pile of toothpicks near
the nest entrance early in the morning
when the nest maintenance workers are
first active this is what it looks like
about 20 minutes later
here it is about 40 minutes later and
the nest maintenance workers just take
all the toothpicks to the outer edge of
the nest mound and leave them there and
what I wanted to know was okay here's a
situation where extra nest maintenance
workers were recruited is this gonna
have any effect on the workers
performing other tasks then we repeated
all those experiments with the ants mark
so here are some blue nest maintenance
workers and lately we've gotten more
sophisticated and we have this to me
color system and we can mark them
individually so we know which ant is
which we started out with model airplane
paint and then we found these wonderful
little Japanese markers and they they
work really well and so just to
summarize the result well it turns out
that yes the different tasks are
interdependent so if I change the
numbers performing one task it changes
the numbers performing another so for
example if I make a mess that the nest
maintenance workers have to clean up
then I see fewer ants out foraging and
this was true for all the pairwise
combinations of tasks and the second
result which was surprising to a lot of
people was that ants actually switched
tasks the same ant doesn't do the same
task over and over its whole life so for
example if I put out extra food
everybody else the midden workers stop
doing midden work and go get the food
they become foragers the nest
maintenance workers become foragers the
patrollers become foragers but not every
transition is possible and this shows
how it works like I just said if there's
more food to collect the patrollers the
midden workers the nest maintenance
workers will all change to forage if
there's more patrolling to do so I
created a disturbance so extra
patrollers were needed the nest
maintenance workers will switch to
Patrol but if more nest maintenance work
is needed for example if I put out a
bunch of toothpicks then nobody will
ever switch back to nest maintenance
they have to get nest maintenance
workers from inside the nest so foraging
Hawk says sync and the ants inside the
nest act as a source and finally it
looks like each ant is deciding moment
to moment whether to be active or not so
for example when there's extra nest
maintenance to work to do it's not that
the foragers switch over I know that
they don't do that but the foragers
somehow decide not to come out and here
was the most intriguing result the task
location this process changes with
colony age and it changes like this when
I do these experiments with older
colonies so ones that are five years or
older they're much more consistent from
one time to another and much more
homeostatic the worse things get the
more I hassle them the more they act
like undisturbed colonies whereas the
young small colonies the two-year-old
colonies of just 2,000 ants are much
more variable and the amazing thing
about this is that an ant lives only a
year it could be this year or this year
so the ants in the older colony that
seem to be more stable are not any older
than the ants in the younger colony it's
not due to the experience of older wiser
ants instead something about the
organization must be changing as the
colony gets older and the obvious thing
that's changing is its size so since
I've had this result I spent a lot of
time trying to figure out what kinds of
decision rules for a simple local
probably olfactory chemical rules could
an ant be using since no ant can assess
the global situation that would have the
outcome that I see these predictable
dynamics and who does what tasks and it
would change as the colony gets larger
and what I've found out is that ants are
using a network of antenna contact so
anybody who's ever looked at answer see
no touch antenna they smell with their
antennae when one ant touches another
it's smelling it and it can tell for
example whether the other ant is an
estimate because ants cover themselves
in each other through grooming with a
layer of grease which carries a colony
specific odor and what we're learning is
that an ant uses the pattern of its
antenna contacts the rate at which it
meets ance of other tasks in deciding
what to do and so what the message is is
not any message that they transmit from
one ant to another but the pattern the
pattern itself is the message and I'll
tell you a little bit more about that
but first you might be wondering how is
it that a gnat can tell for example I'm
a forager I expect to meet another
forager every so often but if instead I
start to meet a higher number
nest maintenance workers I'm less likely
to forage so it has to know the
difference between a forager and a nest
maintenance worker and we've learned
that in this species and I suspect in
others as well these hydrocarbons this
layer of grease on the outside of ants
is different as ants perform different
tasks and we've done experiments that
show that that's because the longer an
ant stays outside the more these simple
hydrocarbons on its surface change and
so they come to smell different by doing
different tasks and they can use that
task specific odor in particular
hydrocarbons they can use that in their
brief internal contacts to somehow keep
track of the rate at which they're
meeting ants of certain tasks and we've
just recently demonstrated this by
putting extract of hydrocarbons on
little glass beads and dropping the
beads gently down into the nest entrance
at the right rate and it turns out that
ants will respond to the right rate of
contact with a glass bead with
hydrocarbon extract on it as they would
to contact with real-ass so I want now
to show you a bit of film and this will
start out first of all showing you the
nest entrance so the idea is that ads
are coming in and out of the nest
entrance there they've gone out to do
different tasks and the rate at which
they meet as they come in and out of the
nest entrance determines or influences
each ants decision about whether to go
out and which tasks to perform this is
taken through a fiber optics and
microscope it's down inside the nest in
the beginning you see the ants just kind
of engaging with the fiber optics
microscope but the idea is that the
answer in there and each ant is
experiencing a certain flow of ants past
it a stream of contacts with other ants
and the pattern of these interactions
determines whether the ant comes back
out and what it does when it comes back
out and so you can also see this in the
ants just outside the nest entrance like
these each
then as it comes back in is contacting
other ants and the ants that are waiting
just inside the nest entrance to decide
whether to go out on their next trip are
contacting the ants coming in so what's
interesting about this system is that
it's it's messy its variable its noisy
and in particular in two ways
the first is that the experience of the
ant of each ant can't be very
predictable because the rate at which
ants come back depends on all the little
things that happen to an ant as it goes
out and does its tasks outside and the
second thing is that an ants ability to
assess this pattern must be very crude
because no ant can do any sophisticated
counting so we do a lot of simulation
and modeling and also experimental work
to try to figure out how those two kinds
of noise combine to in the aggregate
produce the predictable behavior of ant
colonies again I don't want to say that
this kind of haphazard pattern of
interactions produces a factory that
works with the precision and efficiency
of clockwork in fact if you watch ants
at all you end up trying to help them
because they never seem to be doing
anything exactly the way that you think
they ought to be doing it so it's not
really that these haphazard contacts out
of these haphazard contacts perfection
arises but it works pretty well ants
have been around for several hundred
million years they cover the earth
except for Antarctica something that
they're doing is clearly successful
enough that this pattern of haphazard
contacts in the aggregate produces
something that allows ants to make a lot
more ants and one of the things that
we're studying is how natural selection
might be acting now to shape this use of
interaction patterns this network of
interaction patterns to perhaps increase
the foraging efficiency of ant colonies
so the one thing though that I want you
to remember about this is that these
patterns of interactions are something
that you'd expect to be closely
connected to colony size the simplest
idea is that when an ant is in a small
colony and enact in a large colony can
use the same rule like I expect to meet
another forager every three seconds but
in a small colony it's likely to meet
fewer foragers just because there are
fewer other foragers there to meet so
this is the kind of rule that as the
colony develops and gets older and
larger will produce different behavior
in an old colony and a small one a small
young one thank you